Speaker 1: Let's hear from some people in the
audience. We are going to take some calls via
discord, which you can find at David Pakman dot
com slash discord. Every day can be good or bad
on the discord. We never know what to expect.
Let's start today with Dave from New York City.
Why not? Dave, welcome to the program.
Speaker 4: Hi, Mr. Pac-Man. How are you?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, thanks.
Speaker 4: Great. Thank you for taking
my call. This is actually my first time calling
in and I just I wasn't even sure. But you said
please directly get to the question. I noticed
that. And this this ties into my question.
You seem to have a very good amount of sponsors
on the show, including Blinkist and some others.
I actually did try Fume and
it's kind of working out for me,
but I wanted to ask you if you have any advice
for people with a pattern of self-sabotage.
Speaker 1: And this has to do with the sponsors.
Speaker 4: Well. Well, I would say because there
is blinkist and there is privacy and
there are things that I feel would help
me. And they seem to be excellent products.
Speaker 1: You're you're a guy who sabotages
yourself. Is that what you're saying?
Speaker 4: Yes. I have a pattern of
self-sabotage. And I think that
one of those things is recognizing
the services that you've recommended
and not being proactive enough about
following up on them, even though I think
that they would help me. And that ties into
a general self-sabotage issue. And I was
wondering if you have any advice for people
who have chronic self-sabotage patterns?
Speaker 1: Well, I think the most important
thing would be to get a therapist. I mean, that's
really that that would be the most important thing
more than anything I could say. But so
in what ways do you sabotage yourself,
like in work and in relationships?
Speaker 4: Not so much in relationships. I've,
I've I've always felt and I know that I'm a
great partner when it comes to relationships. But
in terms of work, yes, sometimes my, my current
job, I have a certain level of freedom and
I, I kind of show up where I want, what I want.
And sometimes that leads to me not showing up
even though I need the money. There are other
issues where in terms of I do have a therapist
and I do take medication. I'm not always I'm
not always wonderful about the consistency
of doing so. And I just logged on to YouTube and
I saw that you had a video saying taking your
calls in 15 minutes and I figured I would try.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, listen, I appreciate
the call. I want to be careful not to get out
of my lane. I think you're doing exactly the
right things by working with a therapist, and
and that is exactly what I would keep doing.
But I'm sure you're exploring this, but I think
figuring out why the self-sabotage is happening
would probably be extraordinarily useful as a
first step in figuring out how to control it.
Speaker 4: Thank you. Do you have any
book recommendations? Because it sounds
it sounds like you're an avid reader.
Speaker 1: Yes. On my website go to David
Pakman dot com. Click on recommendations, hundreds
of book recommendations there by category.
Speaker 4: Okay. I'll look into that.
Speaker 1: All right, Dave from New York City,
thank you so much for the
call very much. Appreciate it.